chaque espace ça mène à une découverte
une trentaine de pièces en céramique des
éponges suspendus ou des cartons
d'emballage est né en allemagne
installés en france l'artiste
international jan kopp a investi les 350
mètres carrés du centre d'art de la
graineterie yaoi quand on parle du
travail de jan kopp généralement ce qui
ressort tout de suite c'est la grande
variété de ses productions yann c'est à
la fois un vidéaste c'est un dessinateur
il produit des installations et produit
des sculptures verrière galerie grenier
chaque espace de la graineterie est
investi pour cette exposition très
personnel qui oscille entre les
différents espaces temps et moi c'est
vraiment cet aspect du travail de yann
qui m'intéressait beaucoup puisque alors
sans être architecte les questions
d'architecturé espaces c'est vraiment un
fil conducteur dans la carrière de
l'artiste et il a vraiment cette
capacité d'inventer de réaliser des
oeuvres et des installations qui sont
toujours extrêmement juste par rapport
au lieu qu'il investit pour cette
exposition baptisée après la mère
s'était évaporé l'artiste a produit
spécifiquement pour la verrière de la
graineterie une installation poétique à
partir des planches de mer
il a collecté 7 ou 8 éponge de mer c'est
ce que vous pouvez voir vraiment autour
de vous et il invite le visiteur à
marquer une pause puisque cette
installation et mobile est en fait en
fonction des conditions climatiques en
fonction d'un système de poids et de
balancier tout ce que vous voyez
retrouvent autour de vous est amené à
bouger lentement ou pas autour de
l'exposition un parcours sensoriel est
proposé pour les enfants de 6 à 36 mois
les plus grands pourront ainsi découvrir
d'autres ateliers adaptés à leur âge